having a career
year Dakota Joshua in on
go and omark makes the save
and Dakota John Joshua walks in still
gets a quality scoring chance on the
back check by loo High danger chances
off the rush in the league but they
have the second most Rush goals
in the league and Maron scores a
shorty Boston they had a hard time getting
to their game against Calvary but it's a
nice read it's a lazy play by Vancouver on
their power play they gave up a short handed
go to first Spirit against Carolina
game they came back and one but again
just some laziness not attention to detail by
Vancouver they top guys on the ice and it's a
nice Carin is six native pulls a shot on
Mark hoglander to Joshua right in front
and hoglander recent acquired from
Calgary can't win the face off poock
bounces off the giant Nikita zadorov
who appears to favor his right
hand a deflected shot saved by
Demco Lind Holm driver drives it around
M he had that chance Patterson and Quinn
Hughes misses wide to zadorov Garland
a water bug Deeks and sidorov gets a
cannon of onetime Steen flips it over
to geki Steen on the end boards and
a shot by geeky to a career high 10
games poock a snapshot gobbled up by
Demco Cole Jake to brus a one-time on a sweet
touch feed from hampus lindol Lind Holm off
Miller skates Brock besser and a great save by
omark sliding to his left deny Miller take a look
at the hit by Miller I mean that's a good stop po
right there and Miller gets the opportunity what
a stop by lenaar pass the red line geeky from
forward drop pass Parker W spoon up high 2011
KS maoy on
dco
Miller Coy steals hen a break and
he scores two shanding goals for the
BRS
Jack all over the ice good job right there
fighting through kind of a moving pick charie
Coyle kept his stick in a good spot to make the
steal has a chance to make a play to hen Heinen
attacks go ahead Force ptis have to play some
defense good speed by Heinen great prote to the
corner Fredick muscles in the SL one hands it to
forbert he tees it up and Frederick and Frederick
makes a nice play back to the point Saka to poock
his stick shatters and the puck ends up in the
net I'm curious who's going to get credit for this
goal who did it hit last the net and it did it go
in off geeky did it go in off Myers it definitely
goes off his left skate and his reaction It
Gets behind demo but if HEI gets a piece of that
that'll be his goal if not it's going to be panox
go I believe it hit Kiki what a wild first minute
we've had tonight two short H is in a broken stle
zaga SC two goals in the first 49 seconds of
the second period and the Bruins are blowing
Vancouver to the offensive zone the hard wrap
around by makoy the touch pass on the backand
on the rightwing boards by P and then a beautiful
play up by svan reke not sure why Vancouver is
overc committing to a guy like van reik who
doesn't have a ton of speed going on across
the Blue Line Hughes through the slot besser
Pon Miller and centers and Dakota Joshua digs
away and Omar finds it the BR and coil break it up
grizzli demp Co angles his stick Quinn Hues hard
around sudor kind of bounced away
from Vancouver when they had chances
in primaries of the ice here's another one
sud wide open in between four Bru players
he finds the quiet area the overhead will show
you exactly where this Puck went back to maoy 49
throws it toward goal didn't
get there poock whips it off
P's legs zaka pokes it to poock Wheels it into the
slot Miller sends zidor off ahead to Myers and
he misses wide and P off the races a shot with
purpose trying to create the rebound we
the hash marks coming late missed the net
blocker side I don't think Omar got a piece of
it and Ricochet off the backboards and if it's
not so late in the Shi but Poss and hasn't
reached that threshold yet since Omar CAPA
save and hoglander in the eyeses of the
official knocked it in swerves over the
line lafy flattens lowo and
forts two goals in his kak debut POS
knock One Touch get gets it back and
far is a Bullet Pass it's a good effort right
after the face off to get possession we talked
about that second and third effort with this
man advantage that might not been there on
the first pile play in tonight's action
that's a long dist Lena Sark will have
his first shot out of the Season his seventh
of his career 40 the final against the kxs